[Music]
when you look at public opinion one of
the clearest markers of how dramatically
things have shifted is the number of
people who say that they know an openly
gay or lesbian person back in 1985 it
was 24% of Americans who said they knew
a open gay or lesbian person by last
year that had shifted up to 88% and so
you know we actually dedicated the book
it's a statistics book but we dedicated
the book to an unknown number which is
the number of people who have had the
courage to come out and that's an
impossible number to document or
quantify but I think it is the starting
point for the revolutionary progress
that has been made you know Harvey Milk
and other pioneers of gay and lesbian
liberation made that basic point that
coming out was a first step towards
greater equality because visibility
would lead straight Americans to
understand and accept and embrace and
advocate for equality for LGBT folks and
so this movement toward acceptance I
think is completely intertwined with the
growing visibility and openness and
honesty that LGBT folks have embraced I
do think data collection and the
dissemination of survey results and
polls is really important at the same
time I think you know if we're talking
about what the single most important
factor might be in terms of the
revolution toward greater equality for
LGBT people I think you got to look at
the media and the idea that media
portrayals have shifted so dramatically
that's one of my favorite chapters in
the book actually the section on film
and TV and other forms of media which
when you look at early television
portrayals in the 70s and 80s there were
occasional game
leading characters but generally the
laughingstock of any given show and the
you know the very first gay couple was
on a Norman Lear series called hot L
Baltimore about this hotel in Baltimore
if that program wasn't even broadcast in
Baltimore and it was canceled after a
handful of episodes and it was preceded
by this warning you know to make sure
parents didn't allow their children to
be corrupted by the morally questionable
content and so you fast-forward from
that to something like Will & Grace or
The Ellen DeGeneres Show where you have
open gay and lesbian characters actually
living their lives and people can
quibble and I think for good reason with
some of the portrayals but when you look
at the overall trend just the very fact
that mainstream television and network
television is showing and embracing
healthy gay characters and committed
relationships and in a really positive
light I do think that has been
fundamental to the changes we've seen
and then I also think that the ongoing
collection of data through organizations
like Gallup and the Williams Institute
is also fundamental in terms of
reminding people but there is this trend
towards greater acceptance and I think
one you know that that growing
acceptance as reflected by the numbers
leads people to be more open with
pollsters so that if gallops numbers on
you know should same-sex activity be
legal as those numbers go up or should
same-sex marriage be be legalized as
those numbers go up I think that
reporting in turn encourages people to
reveal their inner support so there is a
trend and a cycle where by growing
awareness and going reporting of this
awareness leads to greater acceptance
[Music]
you